[Music]
in 1808 four companies of the second
Battalion to which I belonged were
ordered to Portugal
and that year I first saw the French
being immediately pushed forwards up the
country in advance of the main body many
of us in this hot climate very soon
began to find out the misery of the
frightful load we were condemned to
March and fight under with a burning sun
above our heads and our feet sinking
every step into the hot sand
foreign
though the peasantry sent into our camp
a great quantity of the good things of
their country so that our men regaled
themselves upon oranges grapes melons
and figs and we had an abundance of
Delicacies which many of us had never
before tasted
among other presents a live calf was
presented to the rifles so that
altogether we feasted in our first
entrance into Portugal like a company of
alderman
the next day we again Advanced and being
in a state of the utmost anxiety to come
up against the French neither the heat
of the burning Sun long miles or heavy
knapsacks were able to diminish our
order indeed I often look back with
Wonder at the light-hearted style the
geology and Reckless indifference with
which men who were destined and so sure
the time to fall hurried onwards to the
field of strife seemingly without a
thought of anything but the sheer love
of meeting the Foe and the excitement of
the battle
this video is sponsored by skillshare
the online learning platform
skillshare is a great resource that I've
been using to brush up on my editing and
general business skills one example that
has had a huge effect on voices of the
past was the session creative video
storytelling and editing making the most
of stock footage by Nikki Stevens with
the quarantine over the last year using
stock footage effectively has been an
absolute Lifesaver for a lot of the
videos from the history Brothers
and at skillshare whether you're a
professional or just starting out it's a
great resource for self-improvement and
to start you off the first 1000 of my
subscribers to click the link in the
description will get a free trial of
Premium membership so you can explore
your creativity and make the most of
2021
thanks
on the 17th being still in front we came
up with the French and I'll remember
observing the pleasing effect afforded
by the sun's Rays glancing upon their
arms as they formed in order of battle
to receive us moving on in extended
order under whatever cover the nature of
the ground afforded we began a sharp
fire upon them and thus commenced the
Battle of Elisa
I do not pretend to give a description
of this or any other battle I've been
present at all I can do is to tell the
things which happened immediately around
me and that I think is as much as a
private Soldier can be expected to do
the rifles indeed fought well this day
and we lost many men they seemed in High
Spirits and delighted at having driven
the enemy before them Joseph Cochran was
by my side loading and firing very
industriously about this period of the
day thirsting with heat in action he
lifted his canteen to his mouth Here's
to You old boy he said as he took a pool
of its contents
as he did so a bullet went through the
canteen and Perforating his brain killed
him in a moment
another man fell close to him almost
immediately struck by a ball in the
thigh indeed we called it severely just
here and saw a man named Simmons struck
full in the face by a round shot and he
came to the ground a headless trunk
a man near me uttered a scream of Agony
and looking from the 29th who were on my
right to the left and once the Screech
had come I saw one of our sergeants
named Frasier sitting in a doubled up
position and swaying backwards and
forwards as though he had got a terrible
pain in his bowels he continued to him
and make so much complaint that I arose
and went to him for he was rather a
crony of mine
oh Harris said he as I took him in my
arms I shall die I shall die the agony
is so great that I cannot bear it
it was indeed Dreadful to look upon him
the froth came from his mouth and the
perspiration poured from his face
thank heaven he was soon out of pain and
laying him down I returned to my place
poor fellow he suffered more for the
short time that he was dying than hey
man I think I ever saw in the same
circumstances
I had the Curiosity to return and look
at him after the battle
a musket ball I found had taken him
sideways and gone through both groins
within about half an hour after this I
left Sergeant Fraser and indeed for the
time had us completely forgotten him as
if he had died a hundred years back the
sight of so much blood shed around will
not suffer the mind to dwell too long in
any particular casualty even though it
happens to one's dearest friend there
was no time either to think for all the
action with us rifles just at this
moment and the barrel of my peace was so
hot from continual firing that could
hardly bear to touch it and was obliged
to grasp the stock beneath the iron as I
continued to blaze away James ponton was
another crony of minor a gallant fellow
he had pushed himself in front of me and
was checked by one of her officers for
his rashness keep back you ponton the
lieutenant had said to him more than
once but pontoon was not to be
restrained by anything but a bullet when
in action
this time he got one which striking him
in the thigh I suppose hitting artery if
he died quickly
the Frenchman's balls were flying very
wickedly at that moment and I crept up
to ponton and took Shelter by lying
behind and making a rest for my rifle of
his dead body
strikes me that I revenged his death by
the assistance of his carcass
at any rate I tried my best to hit the
enemies hard
after the battle was over I stepped
across to a nearby house in order to see
what was going on there two or three
surgeons also would arrived at this
house and were busily engaged in giving
their assistance to the wounded but what
struck me most forcibly was that from
the circumstance of some wine butts
having been left in the apartment and
they're having in the engagement being
perforated by bullets or otherwise
broken the red wine had escaped most
plentifully and ran down upon the Earth
and floor where the wounded were lying
so that many of them were soaked in the
wine with which their blood was mingled
foreign
was called after the battle the females
who missed their husbands came along in
front of the line to inquire of the
survivors whether they knew anything
about them amongst other names I heard
that of Cochran called in a female voice
without being replied to
the name struck me and I observed the
poor woman who had called it as she
stood sobbing before us and apparently
afraid to make further inquiries about
her husband
no man had answered to his name or had
any account to give of his fate
I myself had observed him full as
related before while drinking from his
canteen but as I looked at the poor
sobbing creature before me I felt unable
to tell her of his death
Captain leech observed her and called
out to the company does any man here
know what has happened to Cochran
upon this order I immediately related
what I had seen and told the manner of
his death
go then said the captain and show the
poor woman the spot as she seems so
desirous of finding the body
I accordingly took my way over the
ground with fought upon she following
and sobbing after me and quickly
reaching the spot where her husband's
body lay
pointed out to her
it was on the 21st of August that we
commenced fighting the battle of vimero
the French came down upon us in a column
and The Rifleman immediately commenced a
sharp fire upon them from whatever they
could get a shelter behind whilst our
Cannon played upon them one of our
corporals named Murphy was the first man
in the rifles who was hit that morning
and I remember more particularly
remarking the circumstance from his
apparently having a premonition of his
fate before the battle began he was
usually an active fellow and up to the
time he'd shown himself a good and brave
Soldier but on this morning he seemed
unequal to his duty and as we had reason
to know he was not ordinarily deficient
in Courage the circumstance was talked
of after the battle was over
he was the first man shot that day
early on the morning of the battle I
remember being relieved from Pickett and
throwing myself down to gain a few hours
sleep before the expected engagement so
wearied was I with watching that I was
hardly lying down before I was in a
sound sleep asleep which those only who
have toiled in the field can know I was
not however destined to enjoy a very
long Repose before one of our sergeants
poking me with the muzzle of his rifle
desired me to get up as many of the men
wanted their shoes repaired immediately
this was by no means an uncommon
occurrence on looking around in order to
observe if there was any Hut or shed in
which I could more conveniently exercise
my craft a spider House near at hand on
the rise of a small hill so I gathered
up several pairs of the dilapidated
boots and shoes and immediately made for
it
seating myself down in a small room as
soon as I entered I took the tools from
a haversack and prepared to work and as
the boots are the captain of my company
were amongst the bad lot and he was
barefooted for want of them I'll
commence with them
hardly had I worked a quarter of an hour
on a cannonball the first announcement
of the coming battle Came Crashing
through the walls of the house just
above my head and completely covered the
captain's boot as it lay between my
knees there were only two persons in the
room at the time an old and a young
woman and they were so dreadfully scared
of this sudden visitation that they ran
around the room making the house Echo
with their shrieks
for my own part although I was more used
to such sounds I thought it was no time
and place to mend boots and shoes and so
being thus left alone in my glory I
shook the dust from my apron gathered up
the whole stocking trade from the floor
and hastily replacing my tools in my
have a sec followed the example of the
Mistress of the mansion and her daughter
and bolted out of the house
when I got into the open era found all
in a state of bustle and activity the
men falling in and the officers busily
engaged while 20 or 30 mouths opened at
me the moment I appeared calling out for
their boots and shoes where's my boots
Harris you humbug give me my shoes your
old sinner the captain's boots here
Harris instantly make haste and fall
into the ranks as quickly as you can
there was indeed no time for Ceremony so
Letting Go the corners of my apron I
threw down the whole lot of boots and
shoes for the men to choose for
themselves Captain leech ordered a
section of our men to move off with
double quick and take possession of a
windmill which was on our left I was
amongst this section and set off full
cry towards the mill on Captain leech
spied and ruled out to me by name into
return hello you there Harris he called
fall out of that section directly we
want you here my man I therefore wheeled
out of the rank and returned to him you
fall in amongst the men here Harris I
shall not send you to that post
Cannon will play upon the mill in a few
moments like hail and what shall we do
he continued laughing without our head
Shoemaker to repair our shoes
I myself was very soon so hotly engaged
loading and firing away enveloped in the
smoke I created and the cloud which hung
about me from the continued fire of my
comrades that I could see nothing for a
few minutes but the red flash of my own
peace amongst the white Vapor clinging
to my very clothes this is often seen to
me the very greatest drawback upon our
present system of fighting forced in
such State on a calm day until some
friendly Breeze of wind clears the space
around a soldier knows no more of his
position and what is about to happen in
his front or what has happened then the
very dead lying around whilst groans and
shouts and a noise of Cannon and
musketry appeared to almost shake the
very ground
seemed hell on Earth I thought
it was just at the close of the battle
of vimero the Dreadful toil and noise of
the engagement had hardly subsided and I
began to look into the faces of the men
around me to see who had escaped the
dangers of the hour four or five days
back I'd done the same thing at rolitha
one feels indeed a sort of curiosity to
know after such a scene who was
remaining alive amongst the companions
endeared by Good Conduct or disliked
from Bad character during the hardships
of the campaign I saw that the ranks of
The Rifleman looked very thin it seemed
to me one half had gone down
the battle was just over a flag of truce
had come over from the French a
Frenchman lay close beside me he was
dying and called to me for water
I need not say that I got up and I gave
it to him
whilst I did so down galloped the major
in front just in the same good spirits
he'd been in all day plunging along
avoiding with some little difficulty the
dead and dying which was strewn about he
was a regular Gooden a real English
Soldier and that's better than if he had
been the handsomest Ladies Man in the
army
the major just now disclosed what none
of us I believe knew before namely that
his head was as bald as a Coots and that
he had covered the nakedness of his knob
up to the present time by a flowing
caxon which during the heat of the
action had somehow been dislodged and
was lost a guinea he kept crying as he
rode to any man who will find my wig the
man I remember not withstanding the side
of the wounded and dead around them
burst into shouts of laughter as he went
and a guinea to any man who will find my
wig was the saying amongst us long after
that affair
foreign
and here let me bear testimony to the
courage and endurance of that Army under
trials and hardships such as few armies
in any age I should think endured I've
seen officers and Men hobbling forward
with tears in their eyes from the misery
of long miles empty stomachs and ragged
backs without even shoes or stockings on
their bleeding feet and it was not a
little that would bring a tear into the
eyes of a Rifleman of the peninsula
youths who had not long been removed
from their parents home and Care
officers and men have worn hardships and
probations such as we have little
conception of and yet these men faint
and weary with toil would brighten up in
a moment when the word ran amongst us
that the enemy were at hand
foreign
[Music]